this is jaco podcast number 106 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening now in
podcast 105 we finished just as the 1 7
calves flew out of the I drink valley
after keeping it together during a
vicious three-day fight where they
suffered some massive casualties 79
killed in action 121 wounded and and on
top of that the battlefield was littered
with enemy dead with the estimates of
enemy dead to be between 500 and a
thousand and we stopped there where the
where the 1 7 calves left the
battlefield so if you haven't listened
to 105 yet go back and listen to that
before continuing with this podcast 106
because even though the 1 7 left the
battlefield the battle wasn't over yet
and one of the one of the events that I
didn't really talk about in the first I
drank podcast on 105 was the fact that
two other battalions had arrived on the
ground to reinforce the one 7 and it was
the 2nd battalion 5th Cavalry commanded
by Lieutenant Colonel Robert Tully and
the second battalion 7th cavalry led by
Lieutenant Colonel Robert McDade now
most of the battalions men from those
two battalions had landed at LZ Victor
which was about 2 miles away from x-ray
and they had patrolled to x-ray on foot
arriving for the most part without
incident and then things seemed to
settle down a lot on x-ray 1 7 left and
once 1 7 had left the battlefield 2 7
and 2 5 or still there so at that point
that portion of the battle was over
and to seven and to five could have
likely been extracted the helicopter
pretty securely just at 1/7 had been it
seems that general Westmoreland did not
like the idea of to seven and to five
pulling out he thought that that would
appear as a retreat so he ordered that
to 5 and to seven secure LZ x-ray for
the night and then the next day they
would move by foot patrol to another LZ
called LZ Albany which was about 2.5
miles to the north and then b-52 bombers
we're gonna rain down bombs on LZ x-ray
and the surrounding areas they didn't
expect a lot of resistance because
things had settled somewhat down so much
on LZ x-ray that if you remember even
towards the end of the last podcast
there was reporters came in and landed
in LZ x-ray and were doing camera shots
and interviewing people so it was pretty
settled down they felt like it was over
and they didn't expect much resistance
on this movement from LZ x-ray to LZ
Albany so let's go back to the book the
book is We Were Soldiers Once and young
by general Hal Moore and joe galloway
and like i said there wasn't much
resistance expected and here's what it
says in the book the word among Bob
McDade z' troopers was that it was going
to be a walk in the Sun a stroll over to
another landing zone where the
helicopters would come in and extract
them the first leg of the journey home
to on K base the word was wrong
and these guys even though there hadn't
been much fighting going on they were
actually a little bit tired because they
had been awake on the ground so here we
go just before Alpha Company 2nd
battalion moved out its commander
captain joel sedin ease put out an
unusual order his executive officer
lieutenant Larry Gwyn who were going to
hear a lot from Lieutenant Larry Gwyn
remembers it well the company had been
on 100% alert for over 52 hours we were
in such a state of exhaustion the
captain said deenis directed that each
man take to a pc tablets aspirin with
caffeine a move designed to increase the
mental alertness of the troops so there
you go take a little caffeine a little
aspirin get you guys get your heads in
the game because they've been awake for
a long time and again they're not
expecting much but they still been on
the ground in a hot LZ for a while back
to the book lieutenant Ali through the
battalions communication officer was
with Headquarters Company we were told
that this would be a tactical move there
was a lot of stuff on the battlefield
equipment supplies captured stuff that
had to be policed up and blown up all in
a hurry up situation I was personally
carrying an RC 292 antenna in addition
to my regular combat load I weighed
about 140 pounds my normal combat load
was 40 or 50 pounds the two nine two
antennae weighed 60 pounds the
temperature must have been 96 and the
humidity was the same we were moving as
fast as we could through the elephant
grass and scrub oaks some high canopy we
were humping everyone was as tired as
could be so we're already in a rough
situation we've been on the ground for
52 hours and we're gonna move two and a
half miles doesn't sound very far but
when you're carrying so he's already
scared a hundred pounds is 40 50 pound
combat load plus his antenna and
everyone else is carrying all kinds of
extra stuff but they're pulling off the
LZ 96 degrees out 96 percent humidity
and walking through the jungle is never
easy it's up and down
little terrain features going through
various foliage is hard so this is not
easy not the biggest guy to buy the one
hundred and forty hundred fifty pounds
which guys were smaller back then yeah
but then they are now ya know 100 pounds
that's that's no joke
that's no joke back to the book
lieutenant Gary Gwynn of Alpha Company
says the jungle around us got heavier
and heavier that's when things got a
little scary
there was a sudden absence of any air
cover the guys were silent and I
wondered where our helos and our aerial
rocket artillery ships were we had not
changed formation tactically but
physically we had to move in much
tighter to maintain visual contact
because of the undergrowth the terrain
forced our flaker flankers in so at this
point there they'd had a bunch of air
cover that don't have any air cover
right now and now the terrain is making
them get closer and closer together
because if you and I are on patrol I
don't I want to keep you in visual range
I want to be able to see you and so if
all the sudden there's elephant grass
well the only way to keep visual of you
is for you to get close to me and for me
to get close to the next guy and so
everyone starts to compress and he's
talking about the flankers being out
there a lot of times when we patrol in
formation you'll put people out on the
flanks within visual range but they'll
be stretching the visual range but
they're out there to make sure that
there's no one sneaking up on you and so
they've that it's getting dense now to
the point where they can't keep their
flankers out so now you're losing some
of that flank security back to the book
Guin says alpha companies column order
integrity had been good until two
prisoners were captured and everything
came to a sudden halt when I arrived sir
Jeannie's sue Jeannie's was
interrogating the two they were in mint
condition new weapons grenades new gear
but both were feverish terrified and
shaking none of us in company
headquarters had seen alive North
Vietnamese up close these were not the
last we would see this day we gave them
water and advised the battalion
headquarters so all of a sudden I got a
couple of prisoners
little scary to me when the prisoners
that we take have brand new weapons new
grenades new gear I mean we at least
know that they're fresh maybe they're
not combat hardened but we know that
they've got some good they're well
supplied which is a scary thing in this
type of war
so this is this is kind of we're looking
back hindsight of course being 20/20
this is this is an error or a or a
mistake that gets made right now and of
course mistakes happen all the time and
they they don't get capitalized on by
the enemy
sometimes by luck sometimes by skill of
the enemy this is one of those mistakes
that it gets capitalized again whether
it's by luck or plan probably by luck
maybe it's a little bit of both you
wouldn't think much of it if things
didn't go the way they did you know late
life and I used to have this
conversation a lot I mean you don't know
when things are gonna go wrong mmm and
and seriously you can be on the
battlefield and you can you can say hey
everyone go left and everyone goes left
and everything turns out great or you
can say everyone go right and everyone
go right and everyone thing turns out
great if you go left and you happen to
go to where the enemy was waiting in
ambush for you to go now you're you're
you just made a bad tactical call the
the thing that made it about talk calls
that the enemy happened to be there you
couldn't know that mmm and if you'd been
if you'd said go right you'd great made
the greatest call ever because the enemy
was over there waiting for again you
don't know where the enemy's gonna be
don't have that luxury so sometimes you
make the best tactical decision you can
make and it turns out bad now we can
look back at this hindsight being 20/20
of course and and critique what's about
to happen so we'll talk a little bit
more about it here's what goes down back
to the book captain george forrest
commander of Alpha Company 1st battalion
5th Cavalry was more than 500 yards to
the rear so these guys are in a long
column of March group of people McDade
asked all the company commanders to come
forward so McDade as the company is the
battalion commander and he tells all the
company's commanders to come forward so
he's McDade up at the front of this
column and who knows how big they are
you know he says he's 500 yards there
but this whole thing probably spanned
out probably six seven hundred maybe
800 meters we're getting close to a
kilometer in length of people just
spread out just so everyone understands
it's hard to control 40 guys you know in
a line of March with any kind of control
that spread out over 200 meters that's
challenging you get 500 to 600 guys
spread out over almost a kilometre we
have a serious command and control issue
so now what he's doing to overcome this
issue is telling all the all the company
commanders so there's three companies
that are out there actually there's more
than that but there's multiple companies
out there he tells all the company
commanders hey come to my position at
the front of this thing so we can talk
about what's happening mmm back to the
book captain Fesmire the Charlie Company
commander was also moving up the cow
column to toward mcdhh aides position
with him or his two radio operators his
artillery his artillery for digs or
observer
lieutenant Sydney Smith and his radio
men as well as first sergeant Franklin
Hance so so I want you to think about
that or let me explain this to you a
little bit more here's the Charlie
Company commander
he's moving for so he's leaving his
company and with him he brings his two
radio operators so who does that leave
with the company there might be one
platoon guy left that's a radio operator
maybe one in each platoon but there
there's he's pulling the the
communications node out of the company
right there he brings forward his
artillery observer so this is the guy
that's gonna be able to place artillery
other guys can pick up the slack but not
as well as this guy can do it
he brings lieutenant Sydney Smith and
his radio men so that means that so
sorry the artillery observer is
lieutenant Sydney Smith but that guy
brings his radio man as well so there's
another guy out of the loop and then the
first sergeant the company first
sergeant so now that's the leadership
the company leadership is now from from
Charlie Company has now gone they're
moving up forward to talk about it
and so here they give a kind of an
overview of what's going on here it is
this is what back to the book this is
what was happening Sudi knees alpha
company was moving forward toward the
Albany clearing so they've they've now
approached they're kind of approached is
this LZ Albany that's what they're
talking about the Albany clearing alpha
company the Sioux Jeanne's Alpha Company
was moving toward the Albany clearing
Colonel McDade and his battalion command
group were with Alpha Company the other
company commanders had left their
companies under orders and were moving
up to join McDade for a conference so
the other company commanders are not
with their companies anymore the
battalion was strung out along the line
of march for a distance of at least 550
yards so half a kilometer the men of
Delta Company were lolling around on the
ground Charlie Company had flankers off
to each side but were mostly taking a
break sitting or lying down george
forest men at the tail of the column or
in a wedge formation and also had flank
security posted the men a battalion were
worn out after nearly 60 hours without
sleep and four hours of marching through
difficult terrain visibility in the
chest high elephant grass was very
limited bad situation to be in
here's Lieutenant Gwyn talking we had
been there a short time five minutes
when I heard some rounds fired near our
first Platoon I thought they must have
caught up with those NVA stragglers then
everything opened up opened up the
firing just crescendoed they hadn't
found the stragglers they had run right
into the North Vietnamese I was out in
the grass away from the trees when it
started the rounds were so fast and
furious overhead they were knocking bark
off the trees I ran to them one round
struck the tree I was crouched next to
an inch over my head I said holy shit
and ran to join Joel we all got down
then I heard this sickening lump of
mortar fire landing where I had seen our
second platoon disappear
the most savage one-day battle of the
Vietnam War had just begun
the second battalion 7th cavalry had
walked into a hornet's nest
the North Vietnamese reserve force the
550 man 8th battalion 66th regiment had
been bivouacked in the woods off to the
northeast of McCain's column so you've
got fresh soldiers that had been waiting
they were the reserves that whole
earlier battle in the hide rang with the
1 7 calves this this vietnamese group
the 66th regiment 8th battalion 1666
regiment had been waiting in reserve and
now they just so happened to be in the
line of march where these were the two
where the two five is coming through or
sorry the two seven is coming through
here's what colonel and who again this
was the Vietnamese commander here's what
he had to said say I think this fight of
November 17th was the most important of
the entire campaign I gave the order to
my battalions when you meet the
Americans divide yourself into many
groups and attack the column from all
directions and divide the column into as
many pieces move inside the column grab
them by the belt and thus avoid
casualties from the artillery and air we
had some advantages now let me just talk
about that one real quick okay two
things
first of all get the battalion split up
right and if you hear and I always talk
about the common theme of keeping things
together keeping people consolidated
keeping your groups where they can
mutually support each other his goal is
the opposite of that get them split up
so they can't support each other that's
number one so contrary to that what you
should always be doing as a leader is
trying to keep your forces as
consolidated as possible so that they
can they can maneuver well together and
most important support each other to
cover move now the second part of this
is move inside the column grab them by
the belt and thus avoid casualties from
the artillery and air that's something
that we could still see to this day we
talked about it with the Chechen
conflict that was the Chechens mode of
operand modus operandi to take to get
inside and be right next to the Russians
they call it hugging they would get in
there and and get in the same building
as the Russians so you can't called fire
on your own building so that's what the
that's what the Vietnamese were trying
to do now what's beautiful about these
statements think about these two
statements this is beautiful
commander's intent here's all I want you
to do split them up get close to him
that's what I want you to do he's not
saying how to do it he's not telling
each individual group wood where to move
and what to do
eat his hands just split him up and get
it close to him and stay close to him
this is gives the guys on the
battlefield incredible flexibility to
execute that plan
back to the book we had some advantages
on continuing we had some advantages we
attacked your column from the sides at
the moment of attack we were waiting for
you this was our reserve battalion and
they were just waiting for their turn
the 8th battalion had not been used in
fighting in this campaign
they were fresh spec for Dick Ackerman
was the right flank point man in the
recon platoon which was itself the point
of the battalion says Ackerman we were
going to the left to a clearing we had
gone about a hundred feet when we heard
some shots then more shots and finally
all hell broke loose the main brunt of
the attack was right where we had been
standing just a few minutes before we
hit the dirt I was laying in the middle
of a clearing and bullets were kicking
dirt in my eyes and breaking off the
grass Ackerman's first sergeant was
standing shouting and giving directions
his shirt was off and he was in a
t-shirt he lifted his left arm to point
and I could see where a bullet had
ripped him ripped open the side of his
arm and part of the side of his chest he
was still giving orders
we were then ordered to another part of
the circle that was weak it was facing
the main area of attack there were
people running everywhere we couldn't
just open fire in that direction because
our guys were there we were on
semi-automatic and picking off whoever
we could be sure of as a target so this
just turns in immediately into chaos and
again this is why
consolidation of your forces is so
important because the minute you have
enemy in between you and other friendly
forces your field of fire is completely
shut off and you're likely when you're
when you are pulling the trigger you
have a good chance that you're gonna
shoot some of your own guys so that's
what again why consolidations of forces
is very very important now I say this
all the time
I'll make the caveat again are there
times where you can get away with with
splitting your forces and there's other
times that it makes sense yes absolutely
there are times that it makes sense and
we did all kinds of operations overseas
where we had different units out on the
battlefield that were split up and
maneuvering from different areas we did
it all the time but you have to know and
understand the risks you have to know
and understand the risks of splitting
forces of having enemy in between of
trying to consolidate back together
which is very very difficult you just
have to really think about what the
risks are and how you can mitigate those
risks sometimes you can do with the
terrain feature you can put guys in a
certain area where hey I have free fire
because you're down behind a knoll or
you're in a ravine where I know you that
I can't shoot you that that's the type
of thing that you can do to mitigate but
it is something that people think they
can get away with and you know matter of
fact we were doing FTX and it was
interesting we had one of the one of the
females during the planning phase we
haven't planned
just a couple operations just to sort of
get used to planning before we start the
actual FTX mmm this is for those who
don't know we have a company called
echelon front and sometimes we do field
training exercises with the companies
we're working with to get them to help
instill in them the fundamental
principles of combat leadership so it
was funny this this one female she had
come up with this plan and they were
gonna enter this target building from
two different directions talking about
the classroom yes the classroom before
the date and she actually I said well
you know we've said keep it simple and
it can be a little bit confusing if you
start entering a building from two
different sides and you're now you've
got guns pointed at each other and you
know you've got to be careful that you
don't shoot each other and and she
literally said I just don't see how it's
gonna happen that we could go into this
building and we're just gonna start
shooting each other yeah of course
I smiled on the inside and said okay and
and literally the next day during the
FTX phase of the training which we're
using airsoft weapons and you're
shooting at bad guys they came up with a
plan enter the building from two sides
and she entered the building and
literally shot one of her own people you
know she did exactly what she didn't
think could happen yeah and and that's
what people have to understand now you
might think oh well it's this girl or
this female and she was she's not a
military person and it's you know that's
why it happened no I saw seals do it on
the regular you're all hyped up you go
in that room you see a person move and
crack yeah crack them fire a couple of
shots and then you've realized what
happened so so that's what's going on
here
split forces things are going crazy now
here we go
Ackerman's back to the book Ackerman's
recon platoon leader lieutenant pain he
says all hell broke loose up along the
north side of the LZ I turned to my
right and observed some American
soldiers moving toward the Northwest to
set up positions and they went down in a
hail of bullets within minutes we were
all under heavy attack and my radio
operator and I were pinned down in the
middle of the LZ with the most of the
fire with most of the fire coming from
the north and northwest
lieutenant pains radio opera came alive
as the Alpha Company platoon leaders
reported heavy fighting Payne says
mortar rounds began falling which was a
new experience to everyone since we had
never had any kind of mortar fire
against us the noise level was
unbelievable
I remember pressing my body flatter
against the ground and I have ever been
in my life and thinking that certainly
the highest thing sticking up or my
heels mortars continue to fall in small
arms and machine-gun fire continued at a
hectic pace finally my mind seemed to
adjust and
once again began to think about the
situation we were in and what we were
going to do so you see there's a leader
he's pinned down and this is something
that the insurgents in Iraq would do as
well they're gonna hit you with multiple
different weapon systems you know in a
combined coordinated attack so if you
can imagine if you start hitting people
with mortars well everyone needs to get
down you need to get down you need to
take cover while you're taking cover
that's that's cover they're gonna move
they're gonna maneuver in they're gonna
maneuver in with with heavy weapons or
they're gonna move maneuvering with an
assault squad or they're gonna maneuver
in with vehicle-borne IEDs so this is
same thing happening here as you're
getting more gird which these guys
aren't used to which did not that
there's that much you can do to get used
to it because it doesn't matter it
doesn't help you defend it you can be
used to it you still have to get down
you still have to take cover these guys
are taking cover and what I found
interesting about this was you can see
in his mind for a couple seconds maybe
thirty Seconds he's just going holy crap
I'm gonna die and then finally he says
my mind seemed to adjust and once again
he being think about the situation we
were in and what we're gonna do now this
is where combat experience is helpful if
you haven't been in this situation
before it's gonna take you a few seconds
to adapt and be like oh dang I need to
do something if you haven't been in that
situation before you could end up with
some your it's gonna take you some time
to adjust and it's like we talked about
with self-defense with jiu-jitsu if
you've never been grabbed before and
you've never been ground on before
you've never had them before someone
pulled you before it's your mindset
takes time just to get through that
before you even start thinking about
actually defending yourself you're just
getting used you're just saying the
whole crap why is this happening however
you train all the time then you're used
to it you go oh okay someone's got me
here's what I'm gonna do to get out same
thing was getting punched in the face if
you've never been punched in the face
before it takes some getting used to
you're gonna get punched three four or
five times before you like wait a second
I need to defend myself if you've been
punched before boom oh I just got
punched here's my reaction here's what
I'm gonna do and you're speaking of
jujitsu going back to getting inside
that's the same thing getting close to
someone what they were trying to do what
the North Vietnamese were trying to do
get close
stay close that's the same thing that
you do to is you're trying to avoid the
big punches
you get in close you stay close you keep
the person close to you that's how you
avoid getting knocked out same thing so
train train hard
back to the book alpha companies alpha
come the Alpha alpha company's commander
captain sue genies was in the trees
headed to where he had seen the
battalion command group disappear just
as I noticed a small clearing up ahead I
heard one or two shots to my rear back
where my first and second platoons were
I looked back there was a pause of
several seconds and in slowly all hell
began to break loose
I remember if we were reading the book
by Ernie Pyle and he talked about the
expression all hell broke loose because
we've we just heard it like five times
and he's talking about how it gets
overused but it's real and you can tell
with these guys it's it's just
absolutely real that all hell is
breaking loose and I want to say this
too because I didn't mention this about
Dade McDade who's the battalion
commander McDade is the design commander
he had just taken over the battalion
like a few weeks before and he had moved
from some admin position inside the
inside the the I don't know who's inside
the battalion or inside the brigade but
he had moved from like a sort of an
administrative position into battalion
command so in other words he wasn't
charge of in charge of any troops and
then all of a sudden he was in charge of
troops and then three weeks later
they're going into combat now that being
said he also said that this guy hadn't
been in charge of any troops in like ten
years so he he he had apparently done
his platoon commander his company
command in world war ii in korea so
McDade is an experienced combat leader
but he's out of practice he's out of
practice and more probably more
important or just as important to to
being out of practice is he just took
over so part of being a battalion
commander is that you train and prepare
your troops for combat you get to know
all your man you get to understand their
weaknesses you just can't jump in and
take over and all of a sudden have the
knowledge that you would have if you
were preparing everyone that's why
training is so important that's why we
train so if you are if you are not given
the opportunity to train and learn your
troops you're at a huge disadvantage
you're and you haven't had time to train
them up to the Year standards you know
this guy was in world war ii and korea
he understands combat and so to think
that he wouldn't put his guys through a
you know a certain level of training to
get them up to speed and make sure they
do things like like make sure that
there's uh other people in the chain of
command that can step up a meet having a
succession plan so so like him calling
people forward maybe if he had trained
the battalion he knew that there was
other guys in there that would be able
to take charge he didn't realize that
there was like a little little
hesitation there that was gonna happen
which is what happens yeah so he doesn't
know his his team well enough for this
situation and that's not good
back to the book
captain soo Jeanne's says Larry Gwen and
I hit the edge of Albany on the
northeast side of the clearing as the
column began to receive intense fire we
began to receive sporadic sniper fire
part of the recon platoon had already
reached the island in the island with
her talkin autos in like an island of
woods an island of trees I yelled across
the opening for someone to cover us we
ran to the island at this point I called
my first and second platoons on the
radio almost immediately I lost
communications with first Platoon the
platoon sergeant for the second platoon
came on the radio that was sergeant
first class William a Farrell 38 from
Stanton Tennessee he was a veteran of
World War two and Korea had been a
prisoner of war in Korea and could have
chosen to remain in the States he did
not have to deploy with Vietnam with us
everyone called him Pappy Farrell kept
asking captain's to Jeanne's where he
was telling him that they were mixed up
with the North Vietnamese and had
several wounded and killed
I couldn't pinpoint his location I knew
where he should have been directly east
of our island Pappy then radioed that he
was hit that there were three or four
men with him
all hit I could hear the firing at his
location over the radio I never heard
from Pappy again he did not survive this
confusion that happens is fog of war
stuff this is this is complete fog of
war stuff and by the way the enemy gets
a vote the enemy gets a vote the enemy
can do things like this that you don't
expect the enemy can hit you from
multiple sides the enemy can have a
strategy to get or a tactic to getting
close that's what the enemy's gonna do
you don't know what the enemy is gonna
do actually you don't know what they're
gonna do you don't know they're gonna
have mortars this time hmm back to the
book Lieutenant Colonel McDade himself
recalls when things began happening I
got in with Alpha Company I know I was
trying to figure out what was going on I
moved very fast let's get over there in
those trees and let's all get together
the enemy seemed to be all over the
woods
we had good tight control in the
immediate area and we're trying to
figure out where everybody else was one
of the things I was very concerned with
was people being trigger-happy and just
shooting up the grass I was telling them
make sure you know what you are shooting
at because we are scattered so notice
how he says this we had good tight
control in the immediate area and we're
trying to figure out where everyone else
is this is horrible it shows you two
things when you have good tight control
over people you're okay if you know
where your people are you're okay
there's the one of the worst feelings on
the battlefield is not knowing where
your guys are that is one of the worst
feelings on the battlefield not knowing
where your guys are and sitting there
trying to figure out what everyone else
is which I guess those two are the same
things and so the biggest concern that
he has right now is like he's so
concerned about friendly fire hmm keep
control your people
back to the book the battalion
operations officer captain spires
believes that the the fact that the
commanders were absent from their
companies when the fight started
contributed to the confusion it had the
most effect I think on Charlie Company
their commander captain skip Fesmire
was up with us and Don Cornett the
Charlie Company executive officer was
killed early on so they had no commander
and they just disintegrated so
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield talk about that all
the time this is why this is why when
you see a platoon or a company that
doesn't have any leadership they fall
apart now if you are well-trained and if
you have a good succession plan and if
you've done drills where the company
commander gets killed and you take him
out other people have to step up and
lead yes that is how you prepare for
these situations you have to prepare for
those situations you have to prepare for
leaders to go down but if you have no
one that steps up you're gonna be in a
real hard way
real fast back to the book the entire
area is now alive with North Vietnamese
soldiers who had obviously cut through
the battalions line of march severing
the head of the battalion from the body
Guin saw three G GIS coming through the
high grass running from the area
swarming with enemy I jumped up and
screamed to them leaving my arm they saw
me and headed directly to our position
the first man was a captain our Air
Force forward air controller who is
completely spent I pointed out the
battalion command group which was
huddled to our rear at the at another
ant hill and he crawled toward them he
was followed by the battalion sergeant
major Jim Scott who dropped down next to
me and Scott was followed by a young
very small PFC who was delirious and
holding his guts in with his hands he
kept asking are the helicopters coming I
said yes hang on
Italian commander initially thought that
the incoming rounds were all friendly
fire so think about that the battalion
commander initially thought that the
incoming rounds were all friendly fire
so what's his reaction take cover don't
you back which is actually if you're
getting maneuvered on by an enemy the
worst possible thing you can do is take
cover and not shoot back because that
means the enemy's gonna maneuver faster
on you back to the book he had been
hollering for all of us to cease fire
and the word went out over the command
net but to no avail as the troops on the
perimeter could see North Vietnamese can
you imagine the confusion you've got the
battalion commander on the command net
yelling to everyone to cease fire
meanwhile you can literally see North
Vietnamese and you're shooting and
engaging them this is missus mayhem the
sergeant major major and I were looking
to the rear when I heard a loud blast
the sergeant major yelled I'm hit he had
taken around in the back under his
armpit and there was a large hole
underneath his right arm I told him he
would be okay to bandage it himself this
he did ripping off his shirt then he
picked up his m16 and headed back to one
of the ant hills
I saw the sergeant major a few times
after that and he was fighting like a
demon sergeant major Scott says I took a
bullet through my chest not more than
fifteen or twenty minutes into the
battle
I could see enemy soldiers to our left
right and front in the in platoon and
company sized elements they were up in
trees up on top of ant hills and in the
high grass we weren't exactly organized
we didn't have time everything happened
all at once I didn't see a hole being
dug up prior to 8 p.m. that night we did
use the trees and ant hills recover
within a half an hour there was an
attempt to organize groups into
defensive position in the company area
individuals did this no one in
particular I think that's what saved us
so this is decentralized command coming
out you the only thing that gets them
together is that individuals stepped up
and said okay we need a former perimeter
defense now unfortunately a half an hour
an hour had already passed when they got
to this point
where the individuals start making the
call the other thing is there's a lack
of overall direction hmm so you get to a
point where if everyone knew hey here's
the position we're gonna be in the
battalion here's our formation if
something happens here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna balance this area
there's all kinds of contingency plans
that could have been done here now again
I'm doing hindsight 20/20 which I hate
doing but we are trying to learn and we
are trying to talk to all the military
people that are listen to us that are
out doing operations right now think
about this then I had this I probably
told this story before but when we first
got to Ramadi my one of the junior
officers was taking a patrol out and it
was a combined patrol with some Iraqi
soldiers and some SEALs and he was going
over their patrol route with me and he
got to this big open field and he said
yeah in the morning we have to go across
this field because it's only way to get
from here to there I said well what are
you gonna do when you get to this open
field he's gonna get across it that's
how you need to cross it and he said
well we're gonna walk across it I said
what if you get hit and he didn't really
have an answer I said okay so here's
what you're gonna do leave some guys in
the tree line over here have these guys
bound across to this little dike right
here then those guys can join them cover
move just cover and move across this
field and that's what they did and sure
enough they actually got hit they got
hit with a pretty significant attack and
with mortars and small arms fire and day
cover moved out of the situation but my
point is looking at the terrain
beforehand having a plan and then
executing the plan and dictating the
situation you're gonna be and instead of
letting the the situation dictate what
happens to you don't do that it's not a
good answer
situation dictates that's not a good we
dictate the situation
talked about it before and then have
your like the Vietnamese command was
very broad the commander's intent get
close split them up these guys didn't
have a command like that
what could the opposite of command a Big
Ben stick together stick together keep
integrity well there you go
don't let them in close okay there you
go back to the book sue genies and Gwen
are agree that it was not long after
this at the Alf the commander of alpha
companies missing 2nd platoon lieutenant
Gordon groves staggered into the
American position from the east here's
Larry Guin talkin I saw Gordon Gordy
Grove coming across the field along with
two wounded men they were the only ones
left of his platoon who could move Grove
was distraught we got him and his two
men with us and our met God our medics
working on the wounded then Gordie asked
four men to go back with him to get his
people Joe sure Dinis said Gordie I
can't send anybody about else back out
there it was clear that to leave this
perimeter was deaf everywhere you looked
you could see North Vietnamese Gordie
asked permission to go talk to the
battalion commander so Jeannie said go
ahead he jogged over ask McDade for help
to get his men got a negative response
so he came back to our anthill so this
is one of those classic examples you
hear about old-time people will try and
get you in the the catch-22 question
like the gotcha question well what would
you do if you were in the situation and
you some of you guys were still out
there but you didn't have enough people
to go get him or you were being
overwhelmed what would you do well
here's what these guys did right here
don't know you can't go get them you
send in more people out there they're
gonna die if they die if we send ten
guys out there are 15 guys out there 18
guys out there to go recover discipline
we're gonna lose 18 more guys we're
gonna stay put one fight as best we can
from here we'll get fire superiority
back we'll get our shit together and
then we'll go get these guys mmm
Quinn adds there was a tremendous battle
going on in the vicinity of where we had
come into the clearing and beyond there
in the jungle it was Charlie Company
caught in the killing zone of the ambush
fighting for its life the mortar fire
had ceased the enemy tubes apparently
had been overrun by Charlie Company B
because we found them all the next day
but there were still hundreds of North
Vietnam
calmly walking around the area we were
observing now began the sniping phase of
our battle I call it that because for a
long period of time all we did was pick
off enemy wandering around our perimeter
and this lasted until we started getting
air support everything that had happened
to this point had probably taken less
than 30 minutes
Gwyn saw major Frank Henry the battalion
executive officer lying on his back
using the radio trying desperately to
get some tactical air support and
succeeding the air was on the way but
there was no artillery or aerial rocket
artillery yet Jim spires the s3 ran over
to us and queried Gordon Grove Gordy
Grove as the situation outside the
perimeter where he had just come from
Grove told him there were still men out
there tightened into a small perimeter
but they were all wounded and dying in
the radios had all been knocked out
captain spires asked the second time if
he thought anyone was still alive and
none of us said anything Gwynne climbed
a top a termite hill and began sniping
at the north vietnamese visible across
the clearing in the trees to the south
with zem 16 rifle there were plenty of
targets and I remember picking off 10 or
15 NVA from my position my memories
revolve around the way in which each
enemy soldier felt that I hit some would
simply limp slump limply to the ground
some reacted as if they had been hit by
a truck some that I missed on the first
and second shots kept on milling around
until I finally hit them what we did not
know at the time was that they were
wandering around the elephant grass
looking for Americans who were still
alive and killing them off one by one
North Vietnamese soldiers climbed into
trees and on top of those brush covered
termite Hills and poured fire down on
the cavalry troops troopers trapped in
the tall grass below them in the main
body of the column there was serious
firing including mortar fire both from
both sides the strike at the head of the
column was followed so quickly by the
enemy encircling a soul
that the whole business seemed to erupt
almost simultaneously without doubt some
of some platoons of McCain's battalion
were alert and in as secure of formation
as they could achieve in the elephant
crash brush and thick scrub trees but
the visibility problem made it difficult
to maintain formation and one result was
that American troops were close to one
another then was tactically sound
providing juicy granade juicy targets
for a grenade mortar round or a burst
from ak-47 rifle all down the column
platoon leaders sergeants radio
operators and riflemen by the dozens
were killed or wounded in the first 10
minutes rapidly degrading communication
cohesion and control so this whole thing
that we've talked about up in the spawn
was like a half an hour just a brutal
onslaught that debt kicked off with
massive violence of action
captain Fesmire adds the result was very
intense individual hand-to-hand combat
in the confusion I had no idea exactly
where the company was located when
lieutenant cornet died it was virtually
impossible for me to talk to anyone in
my company the battle had clearly become
an individual struggle for life
again that was the goal of the
Vietnamese was to make it an individual
struggle was to get in close was to
separate people from the main battalion
to split it up into as many parts as
possible so they could pick it apart
spec for Jack Smith who's in Charlie
Company had been a radio operator until
about a week or so before this operation
when he was shifted to a supply clerks
job the events of November 17 are etched
on his mind
Smith's company commander Captain phasma
had like the others been called to the
front by lieutenant-colonel McDade
subsequently many people pointed to this
as a major error and in light of what
has happened it was the firing began to
roll on all around us the executive
officer of my company
a man called don cornet a very fine
officer jumped up and in the best style
of the infantry school yelled follow me
elements of our 1st and 2nd platoons ran
right towards a series of ant hills
within ten feet of them we saw where the
machine gunners behind them firing
point-blank at us men all around me
began to fall like mown grass I had
never seen people killed before they
began to drop like flies and died right
in front of me these were the only
friends I had and they were dying all
around me
private first class James H Shannon was
in Forbes Delta company mortar platoon
the intensity of the fire increase to
the point where Shannon
couldn't hear anything but weapons
firing and here's what he says tone
Johnson came crawling with me hitting
the cheek in the back of the hand the
trees were full of North Vietnamese but
spotting one was almost impossible they
blended in so well I kept raising up to
try and detect a good target Mathew
Shelton who was laying next to me kept
jerking me down as I raised up again a
bullet pierced my helmet straight
through front to back I went down again
and came back and as I came back up a
bullet struck the tree beside my head
from behind I don't know if we were
surrounded or was our own men they were
firing wild anything that moved somebody
shot at it one trooper crawled up next
to me shooting through the grass a few
inches off the ground toward where our
own people lay never thinking what he
was doing I told him to be sure he knew
what he was shooting at the firing
eventually began to slack off Shannon
has no idea how much time elapsed there
was no way to keep track of time in a
fight like this men were wounded and
dead all in the area six were alive that
I know of sergeant Tyler
PFC Carter PFC Johnson PFC Shelton PFC
cones and myself Tyler gave the only
order I heard during the entire fight
try to pull back before they finish us
off Shelton froze to the ground and
would not move the five of us proceeded
to try and pull back but the snipers
were still in the trees soon I was hit
in the right shoulder which for a time
rendered it useless
Tyler was hit in the neck about the same
time he died an arm's length from me
begging for the medic
for William pleasant who is already dead
the last words
Tyler ever spoke were I'm dying sergeant
Tyler 35 was from Columbia South
Carolina the helplessness I felt is
beyond description
within a few minutes I was hit again in
the left knee the pain was unbearable
Kohn's was hit in the feet and ankle we
were wounded and trapped
I could see we were getting wiped out a
buddy helped me bandage my leg he got
the bandage off a dead Vietnamese
I got behind a log and there was a
Vietnamese there busted up and dead this
was behind us so I knew we were
surrounded it's for me it's crazy to
think these are Americans it really is
you know it's crazy to think you you
always think naively so that Americans
have the upper hand all the time but you
know here you are you you you you don't
you don't always have the upper hand
Shannon continues on it appears as if
the ground was opening up and swallowing
the mortar men they fell so fast
a brown wave of death rolled over them
and on into Charlie Company Vietnamese
intermixed with them then reality set in
the enemy-held ground beyond the anthill
the column was cut in half
incoming fire drew our attention back to
the tree line the firing increased
rapidly we returned fire at muzzle
flashes I heard an explosion behind me
turning I saw chai khon grenades landing
all flash and smoke no casualties the
volume of fire became all
most unendurable bullets peeled bark
from trees vegetation disintegrated I
look to lieutenant James Lawrence for
help
saws hi his head violently recoil he hit
the ground
here's another description back to the
book here's what the Vietnam War looked
like in the afternoon of November 17
through the eyes of two of Captain
Forrest Alpha Company rifleman PFC David
a perp lavender of Murfreesboro Illinois
and SPECT for James young of Steelville
Missouri says lavender my platoon was
bringing up the rear we started to
maneuver and work our way up the column
to help those ahead every time we made a
move we were hit by mortars it was
something you can't describe people were
dropping like flies the first blast
killed a young soldier named Locatelli
every time we moved they dropped mortars
on us I know we must have had 12 or 15
wounded out of our platoon including our
platoon leader these were my buddies I
had been with in the Army for two years
the majority of our whole battalion had
been drafted at age 21 and had been this
service for over 18 months all of us
were nearly 23 years old they became my
brothers over time hearing these fellows
scream hearing them killed stuck in my
heart and mind ever since the most
critical part of this fight was the
beginning it was the surprise they had
us in a u-shaped ambush and they had us
cut off with mortars surprise and
violence of action surprise and violence
of action
two key elements of firefights and
here's what young said the other the
other individual introduced a moment ago
there was a grassy field to my left 25
or 30 yards
a sniper off on my right I couldn't see
him but I saw a tracer bullet go across
my hand I felt the wind of that bullet
the same bullet passed over the back of
Smith's neck he was lucky he had his
head down our company commander captain
Forrest came running along our line he
was stopping and telling everybody where
to go he acted as though he was immune
to enemy fire I don't know how he kept
from getting hit so captain Forrest
stepping up and leading and what things
do not happen without leadership so
unless he gets up and makes these things
happen they are not going to happen
that's what you do as a leader you have
to make things happen
talk about it all the time there's an
example of it things do not happen
unless you make them happen now if you
remember that often times in Vietnam
there would be a command and control
helicopter and we talked about this on
105 where the brigade commander actually
came and landed for a little bit and
then left well that was Colonel Tim
Brown and here we have a little section
with talking about what hit what's going
on with him back to the book colonel tim
brown's helicopter was running low on
fuel and the chopper had to return to
refuel brown says i knew they were in a
contact i did not know how severe or
anything else while I was talking to
McDade I could hear rifle fire but he
didn't know what was happening I asked
what happened to your lead unit he
didn't know where's your trailing units
he didn't know and he didn't know what
happened to any of the rest of them
nobody knew what the hell was going on
we were not in a position to shoot a
bunch of artillery or air strikes in
there because we didn't know where to
put them only now that Colonel Brown
began rounding up reinforcements to send
in to help Bob McDade second battalion
the you notice what he wants to know is
where people are yeah that's that's and
you've heard me talk about this before I
used to ask that young junior officers
what's the most important piece of
information you can have on the
battlefield and they'd say oh where the
enemy is and how how many there are and
what kind of weapons there are and no
the most important piece of information
there is on the battlefield is where you
are and I actually tell the same thing
to businesses because sometimes
businesses don't know where they are
because they're not tracking what
they're doing so you ask them hey where
are you and you're in your P&L and your
profit loss they don't know you ask them
where they're doing their so how where
their sales performance is they don't
know well how are we going to make any
changes you need to know where you are
most important piece of information
there is
here's McDade talking again this is the
colonel or the the battalion commander
lieutenant colonel in charge on the
ground in that first hour or so the
situation was so fluid that I was acting
more as a platoon leader than a
battalion commander that's a flat red
flag right your act if you're acting as
a batoon leader and you're in charge of
a platoon is 40 guys mm a battalion is
500-600
and he's acting as a platoon leader
who's brought in the battalion that we
were trying to secure a perimeter I was
trying to figure out what the hell was
going on myself I don't think anybody in
the battalion could have told you what
the situation really was at that time I
can see where this might have left Tim
Brown the brigade commander in the dark
about what was going on I didn't know
myself until things quieted down the
battalion commander adds I could have
yelled and screamed well that we were in
a death trap and all that crap but I
didn't know it was as bad as it was I
had no way of checking visually or
physically by getting out of that
perimeter so all I could do is hope to
get back in touch I wasn't gonna scream
that the sky was falling especially in a
situation where nobody could do anything
about it anyways so if you don't know
what's going on
that means there's a bad problem that
that's that's my assessment and also
it's
also if you I'm not trying to say that
you should cry wolf because you
shouldn't mmm but when things are going
sideways you can wait for them to
develop if you have a grip of what's
happening if you don't know what's
happening you better spin some people up
to come help you and at least get them
spinning at least get them turning that
happens a lot where the guy on the
ground might not fully understand what's
happening make the call and say hey I
need i'm stand by to support stand by
get QRF spun up you know you make those
calls
that doesn't mean send anybody but get
him ready get him closer get him on
standby qf his Quick Reaction Force so
if I'm on the ground also I'm getting
shot at from multiple different
directions I'm not really sure what's
happening I might not say send the QRF
but I'll say hey have the QRF move to
position alpha which is very close to
where I am in case I do need them in 15
minutes or in half an hour or an hour or
right now I've at least made that
progression is that like four just
provide some general awareness yeah so
is your QRF Quick Reaction Force they
might be they might be 30 minutes away
and then it might need 15 minutes of
notification time yeah that means if you
call them right now
they're gonna be here in 45 minutes
mm-hmm 45 minutes from Bad firefight is
not gonna help you yeah yeah so your
first call now
you might bring them in and you pre plan
this this is when I talk about
pre-planning we would always pre-planned
hey if we need QRF we're gonna call you
to this point here we'll call you to
this point here if we need to bring you
on standby we'll call you to this point
let's say this point is 500 meters away
from where we actually are and then we
have one that's right where we are like
you come to this building if we call QRF
you come to this building we're gonna
try and get into that building if you
don't hear from us and we just call for
QRF come to that building we'll be
inside it the best of our ability as
they get closer hopefully you can
establish communications with them
directly but if you start losing control
of the situation this is the thing when
you start losing control of the
situation you call up the QRF and say
hey move to the staging point so now
they're moving you start at that 45
minute clock right now they've all spawn
up there
all getting in their vehicles they woken
up the people that need to get out they
get in their vehicles and they drive so
now they might get to the 500 meters
away and I had the situation under
control and I say hey we don't need you
come in we're okay hold off on what you
got there bombed but they don't care
they'd rather have that because maybe in
30 minutes things that developed to a
point where I need them and now they can
get there in 15 minutes instead of in 45
so again we're not trying to spin up and
waste assets but and actually know who
did this a very similar in that in the
previous podcast the guy that called
Broken Arrow which means troops are
about to be overrun he didn't wait for
anyone tell me he just called he's at
Kay Broken Arrow now it takes some time
for those guys to show up there and by
the time they got there they needed them
mmm similar thing now yeah they don't
advocate yelling or screaming sometimes
you might have to though you know you
might need to get that information
people aren't paying attention what
you're saying it can be impactful if
you've ever been sitting and it's in its
actual operation center where you hear
people yelling it gets attention because
most most military guys don't yell and
scream for no reason they're yelling and
screaming because there's a reason why
they're yelling and screaming mm-hmm
don't recommend it I don't recommend it
but I've heard it you know I prefer the
calm guys mmm-hmm if you gotta yell and
scream then calm down and talk about
what you actually need you can't just
continue to yell and scream because
you'll you won't get through clear
communication mm-hmm you'll calm awesome
office to emotional and you know you
just become hard to understand when
you're screaming yelling calm down get
their attention give a simple clear
concise direction of what you want
back to the book each and every man
still alive on that field American and
North Vietnamese was fighting for his
life
in the tall grass it was nearly
impossible for the soldiers of either
side to identify friend or foe except at
extremely close range Americans in olive
drab and North Vietnamese and mustard
brown were fighting and dying side by
side it may have begun as a meeting
engagement a hasty ambush a surprise
attacked a battle of maneuver and
fact it was all those things but within
minutes the result was a wild melee a
shootout with just gun fighters killing
not only enemy not only the enemy but
sometimes their friends just a few feet
away there would be no cheap victory
here this day for either side there
would be no victory at all just the
horrible certainty of death in the tall
grass unbelievable
horrible horrible back to the book just
forward of the headquarters section of
the column Charlie Company was beginning
to die Charlie company's talk about
Charlie Company a whole company of men
150 guys spec for Jack Smith was with
the lead elements in the Charlie Company
formation near lieutenant Don Cornett
the Acting Company commander when the
company charged into the teeth of the
enemy machine guns in the first seconds
Smith saw one of the radio operators
fall dead with a bullet through his
chest his eyes and tongue bulging out
the men of Charlie Company were firing
in all directions
Smith recalls within a span of perhaps
20 minutes everyone around me was dead
or wounded except me you have to
understand that in our area the elephant
grass was chest-high
once you hit the dirt your world was
about as big as a dining room table your
world's completely confined to that area
and the six or seven men around you at
that point we were isolated Alpha
Company was in the same shape then the
North Vietnamese swept through I believe
they came between alpha and our company
began to shoot people we didn't know if
the noise was from five feet away as
they began to shoot people was friendly
or enemy Smith saw
soldiers take machine guns lie flat on
the ground and begin firing into the
grass often they were firing right into
the muzzles of other American machine
guns people were screaming to stop the
shooting it began to have all the
elements of a massacre nobody was in
control because all the officers were to
the front and our radio operators had
fallen dead on their radio sets no
leadership no communication you know I
talk to businesses that I explained this
to my there's your point yeah it is loud
and clear tell these businesses where
I'm gonna talk to businesses they talk
about this problem and that problem the
other problem their problem is
leadership that's what the problem is
the problem is leadership and this
situation like this where the leaders
are not there to lead you've got serious
problems on your hands especially once
again if you haven't trained people to
lead to step up and lead when the
leaders gone if you haven't trained
people to do that you're gonna have
problems no one is going to lead back to
the book Payne fought the North
Vietnamese had done a much much better
job of anticipating and preparing for
the attack but the Americans who
survived the initial onslaught began to
rally in one respect you could think of
it as little Little Bighorn we were
surrounded with our packs in front of us
shooting it out during the course of
that long afternoon I never saw soldier
not do his duty I never saw anyone who
cowered in the face of the enemy
our backs were against the wall and it
was a matter of survival every person I
saw rose to the occasion so this is the
American troopers are doing what
American troopers do fight even in these
terrible situation no one cowers no one
stands down back to the book shortly
afterward the command came over the
battalion net throw smoke
lieutenant Gwynn moved a little away
into the grass and
man in Albany perimeter all began to
throw smoke grenades
I saw skip Fesmire charlie company
commander throwing smoke I had no idea
what the hell he was doing up here our
perimeter was marked with colors with
all colors of smoke delineating our
positions and shortly after the air
strike started they were the they were a
1e Skyraiders with napalm the first
napalm canisters fell right at the point
where sea genies and I had left the
jungle and came into the clearing we
could see masses of North Vietnamese on
the other side I was sure I was very
sure they were going to come across at
us I think they were cleaning up over
there shooting down at the ground
dispatching our wounded that first
strike was right on target with to
napalm cans
I saw them hit the tops of the trees and
jellied napalm was coming down through
the limbs and the NVA were jumping
trying to get away and being engulfed in
flames I saw that time and time again
lieutenant Gwynn remembers it cleaned
out swath after swath those fuckers
would jump up and try to run they didn't
make it by now the Americans were
cheering and laughing at each strike the
cheering stopped when they dropped
through canisters directly onto the
position where the remnants of the 2nd
platoon had been making their stand it
might have been me but all I could hear
was the cracking of unexpended rounds
burning in the flames that engulfed our
men none of us know if there were any
alive at the time but none of us wanted
to think about it
spec for dick Ackerman of the recon
platoon remembers our artillery was
supporting us so close that we would
occasionally get some shrapnel there
were planes flying close air support we
started digging in everywhere we could
my entrenching tool was attached to my
pack left out in the clearing so I used
my band nap my fingers and someone
else's tool when it was available the
comfort of a trench just big enough to
hold your body is unbelievable no more
than 200 yards away in that tortured
column of desperate Americans one man
prayed for a miracle and the US Air
Force delivered it PFC Jim Shaden Delta
Company who had booby trapped his own
body with a hand grenade was badly
wounded and unable unable to move he was
directly in the path of a group of North
Vietnamese soldiers methodically
sweeping the ground killing his wounded
buddies then here's what he says before
the North Vietnamese got to me half a
dozen of them a pilot came over at
treetop level level turned straight up
and dropped the canister of napalm dead
center on them I never cease to be a
mave amazed at the accuracy of that drop
the heat of the napalm rolled across my
face and body like an open door on a
furnace I owe this pilot more than it is
possibly possible for a human to pay may
God bless all pilots
now we hear from Captain Abuse Tully's
Bravo Company 1st battalion 5th Cavalry
was a was assigned the mission of
attacking to relieve the pressure and
attempt to link up with the beleaguered
battalion reinforcements were also on
the way for the battalion command
perimeter at the head of the column
during the afternoon captain
Myron de Derrick's battle wearied
veterans of the fight at a landing zone
x-ray Bravo Company 2nd battalion 7th
caveat a warning to prepare for a night
air assault into a hot landing zone the
Bravo Company troopers delighted to have
survived the hellish fighting on x-ray
and enjoying a well-deserved rest and a
lot of cold beer back at Camp Holloway
were stunned when they were told they
were being thrown back into a desperate
situation so suddenly so if you
remembered to dirac from podcast 105
from 2 70s Bravo Company to 7 they went
in and helped turn the situation around
at LZ x-ray they fought hard and then
they got extracted
and now they're getting told there's a
bad situation going on again and we
needed to put you back on back in back
on the fight back to the book specialist
John well eNOS Bravo Company mortar
observer was doing some serious
celebrating he had not only survived
x-ray without a scratch but this day
November 18th was his birthday I was 22
years old we were fed and showered new
clothes were available I spent the
afternoon at the men's at the enlisted
men's club drinking beer with the
platoon exchanging stories and
celebrating my birthday around 4:00 p.m.
the dirac came in and told us to saddle
up we were going to rescue the battalion
at about 1600 hours
lieutenant Rick Rescorla recalls captain
- Derek walked up get the company
together battalions catching hell we may
have to go in you're the only petunia
left in the company help all the
toons get their shit together men
spilled out of the clubs and double-time
to their equipment they worked quickly
throwing on their harnesses no protests
but their eyes filled with disbelief
again the dirac then issued the the
shortest frag order in Bravo Company
history we'll be landing from the
southeast open fire - anything on your
left run to your right a hostile landing
with one side of the landing zone held
by the North Vietnamese sitrep from the
ground grim expect to be sandwiched
between friendly and enemy fires at
about 5:45 p.m. Rescorla gathered the
platoons they pressed in close listening
intently for word sergeant first class
Alston Goulston the mortar platoon
sergeant sergeant Staff Sergeant Martin
spec for Vincent specialist wiliness the
towering sergeant Larry Melton 80 or
more young faces hollow eyes you know
the battalion and is in the shit I said
we have been selected to jump into that
shit and pull them out if you fight like
you did at X ray you'll come through it
stay together come out of those choppers
ready to get it on across the field the
first lift ships were sweeping in had
him up captain to direct growled I
turned and walked ahead Fantino trailing
with the PRC 25 the road stretched out
past the permanent hooches of the rear
echelon at Holloway word spread that we
were on a suicide fight tumbling out of
cozy bunks
Holloway's finest line the road to watch
us depart Hawaiian shirts aviator shades
jeans beer cans and hands cooks and
bottle washers the ship burgers
projectionists club runners same army
different species the company
picked up pace a tight dirty brown
column a few of the men carried ak's
trophies from x-ray no one had shaved
noted Rescorla but our weapons sparkled
what outfit are you one spectator asked
the hardcore of Bravo Company second of
the seventh where are you headed to kick
ass I yelled back a deep Rumble ran
through the ranks men yelling cursing
not a man among us would swap places
with these lard asses as we passed
I asked Fantino how we looking back
there his reply no stragglers sir every
swingin dick is with us as we made a
column right to the pickup point I
looked back at our crew no outfit in the
army had ever rendered a route step and
he better than these men at this moment
we piled onto the Huey's without the
usual loading instructions and skidded
away into the fading gray light at 6:45
p.m. the first lift ships roared into
the small Albany clearing and captain to
Derrick's troopers bailed out into the
tall grass
the cavalry had ridden to the rescue but
the killing and dying and terror
continued unabated in outside the
American perimeter as the long night
began once again that's the American
soldier right there barely survived
x-ray get called to go back in and they
pick up the pace
back to the bill captain to derrick road
of the flight in in the situation on the
ground assaulting Albany we picked up
five bullet holes in the helicopter
things were bad I found out when I
landed that the battalion was shot up
pretty bad so he came in the nick of
time to their rescue the main part of
2nd battalion 7th Cavalry Little Bighorn
revisited and here's Rescorla talking
looking sideways I saw a trickle of
blood down the pilots sleeve this is as
they're flying in the choppers dropped a
few feet
the pilot yelled at the gunner the
gunner stalled get out I hesitated get
the fuck out four of us drop the
bone-jarring
ten feet now inside the battalion
command group perimeter Rescorla took
stock and here's what he says the
battalion sergeant major sat against a
tree with a bandits chest we got hit bad
sir
real bad the wounded were gathered
thirty yards from the CP only half my
platoon had arrived the other ships
turned back because of the ground fire
and darkness the perimeter was an oval
island of trees three platoons could man
the perimeter but with the exception of
our people and Pat Payne's recon platoon
there was no unit cohesion colonel
McDade slumped against a tree he looked
exhausted he was exceptionally silent
major Frank Henry his executive officer
was reassuringly active a short fireplug
of a man Henry waved to welcome working
the radius
captain Jill price the fire support
coordinated coordinator crouched beside
him clumps of survivors sprawled inside
the perimeter including several company
commanders lieutenant Larry Gwynn
watched the reinforcements arrive I saw
Rick Rescorla come swaggering into our
lines with a smile on his face an m79 is
on his shoulder and his m16 in one hand
saying good good good I hope they hit us
with everything they've got tonight
we'll wipe them up his spirit was
catching the troops were cheering as
each load came in and we really raised a
racket the enemy must have fought that
an entire but
Italian was coming to help because of
all our screaming and yelling major
henry directed that i round up some men
and police all the ammo resupply which
the choppers brought in on the last
flight it was lying in crates on the far
side of the LZ somehow we got it all
into the perimeter as i came back with
the last load i passed right over the
body of that north vietnamese i'd killed
early in the fight there wasn't much of
him left and i didn't give a damn so i
mean there you go there you see one one
leader makes a difference one leader
makes a difference here these guys are
completely surrounded dead and wounded
everywhere and rick Rescorla comes in
and says good i hope they bring it
tonight we'll wipe them out
back to the book lieutenant Pat Payne of
the recon platoon was just as happy
about the reinforcements as Gwynn we
were all very surprised to see those
helicopters come in we were only
securing one side of the LZ so when the
guys would jump off the helicopter we
hollered them which way to come I had a
feeling we had actually been rescued
that and the fact that the cavalry had
arrived just like in the movies
I admired the courage it took to land in
Albany lieutenant Rescorla was one of
the best combat leaders I ever saw
during two tours in Vietnam he walked
around and kept everyone up by telling
them that done a good job that there was
support now that things were under
control he never raised his voice almost
spoke in a whisper
we were awfully glad to see him and the
others from Bravo Company well got in
there until never no you did a good job
didn't get all negative although he's
actually and he talks about it I think I
think I'm gonna cover it but he talks
about what he was actually thinking was
like this is gonna be really problematic
in his mind he was thinking this is bad
really bad but he didn't show that he
showed hey we're good
bring it you're yours you're good now
good job get ready to get it on
talking a little bit about the the air
support that they're getting back to the
book Chief Warrant Officer Hank
Ainsworth had been overhead in the
second battalion command chopper all day
and here's what he says I was overhead
when the fight started an orbited
overhead too late that night I was on a
freak talking to major Frank Henry
later that evening he called me Henry
said we have critically wounded down
here if we don't get them out they're
going to die
I called medevac and they came out made
a pass drew fire and refused to land to
land Frank Henry knew exactly what to do
about that situation he told Hank
Ainsworth to call the 229th Huey slicks
the old reliables Ainsworth notified the
229th pilots told them and that LZ
Albany was hot but that second battalion
7th cavalry had critically wounded men
who would die if they were not evacuated
says Ainsworth the whole damn unit
volunteered I told them we only needed
two ships
despite Ainsworth call for only two
ships for Huey slicks lifted off from
Camp Holloway turkey farm at 9:50 p.m.
for the 40-minute flight to Albany
Captain Bob Stinnett was again in the
lead followed by a captain Bruce Thomas
Chief Warrant Officer Ken faba and
Warrant Officer Robert Mason and here's
what Stinnett says and only the Huey
pilots thought I'll back their engines
as soon as they touched down to conserve
fuel fuel not tonight
something told me not to do that to keep
the engine turning at a full flight RPMs
they told us the wounded were ambulatory
when we got in there they were all
stretcher cases my crew chief and gunner
had to get out and raise the seats so we
could get all the stretchers in then all
hell broke loose fire was coming in from
everywhere
I immediately pitched I've immediately
pulled pitched and with the RPMs that
flight the ship instantly jumped 30 feet
in the air and kept going up we went so
fast that the crew chief and gunner got
left behind on the ground and I didn't
even know it we just flat left them we
had the wounded inside when we got back
we count
30 holes in my machine that was enough
for me and my Huey the left of three
that went in after da after me took in
medical stuff and brought back more
wounded and my crew major Frank Henry
was on the flashlight at the time till
Sid Jeanne's watched it with Oz the
brave aviators risked everything for the
wounded at Albany
I remember thinking they were the
bravest pilots I had ever seen
they were sitting ducks and I fully
expected to see them shot down at any
moment they were guided in by Frank
Henry you could see the tracers the
aircraft didn't hesitate it a bit they
landed loaded and were gone in seconds
so again you see what that's the
american fighting spirit oh we got a hot
LZ where we probably gonna get shot down
but we've got wounded Americans on the
ground we're going to get them everyone
in the unit volunteers we only need two
aircraft guess what we're bringing four
back to the book after midnight several
shots rang out from inside the perimeter
a trooper twenty yards behind Rusk Orla
inside the perimeter had rattled off a
panic be three rounds Rescorla walked
back and cost out the group in the
middle of a perimeter if I hear one more
round out of you we will turn our
weapons around and open up no one fires
from inside the perimeter if you want to
fire out to the perimeter if you want a
fire get out to the perimeter line
whispered communication took place all
night between isolated elements outside
the perimeter if there was heroism it
was out there in the tiny groups of
wounded and those who had bandaged and
protected them through the night they
were just like hunting buddies said
Rescorla surviving by instinct looking
out for each other lieutenant Larry
green of Alpha Company recalls that late
that night one of alphas missing men
crawled into the American perimeter and
here's what he says sergeant James a
Millar D from our 1st platoon made it
back to our lines his story the NVA had
been shooting our wounded one came up to
him stuck a pistol in his mouth and
fired the bullet exited
the back of his throat knocked him out
and they left him for dead he survived
and when he woke up that night he
started crawling to us the next day was
a real nightmare as we went out to find
our dead and missing I think each of us
cracked up a little bit that day as the
true picture of the action began to
unfold then it came across the radio
Bravo Company had found on one other
survivor from our second platoon he had
been badly wounded in the legs and it
propped himself up against a tree he had
been burned by napalm waiting in the
night and some North Vietnamese had put
a pistol to his eye and pulled the
trigger shot him in the eye blinded him
but he was still alive I saw him being
brought in by stretcher smoking a
cigarette all fucked up so at this point
things had backed off a little bit they
backed off and they actually did the mad
minute which is something that
hackworth talks about and it's something
that they did in the first part of this
book which is hey every one of the
perimeters just gonna shoot a bunch of
rounds like at 6:30 in the morning boom
everyone fire a full load out or a full
magazine or a couple magazines at likely
targets and they did that and that
seemed to calm things down they they
kind of did that once things had already
calmed down a little bit and it was it
was it indicated that maybe things were
calming down a little here's another
thing back to the book the NVA came into
the ambush area that night to recover
their dead and wounded when they found
any of our guys alive they would beat
them to death bayonet them or machete
them to avoid shooting and drawing fire
from us that was during the night they
did that like I said they did the madmen
and here's what here's what lieutenant
Rescorla said about the mad minute he
said this decision was regrettable rifle
fire shattered the silence and the
perimeter was ringed with reckless
firing
little font had been given to that the
remainder of our survivors were sprawled
among the trees and anthills within 500
yards the effective range of our m16s
what the fuck is happening are you
shooting at us the frantic radio calls
started coming in how many troops were
killed or injured by our wake-up call
we'll never be known thank God for the
trees the ant hills and the uneven
terrain captain
Dudley today me third Brigade fire
support coordinator remembers flying out
to Albany at first light the next
morning Tim Brown myself Mickey Parrish
took a while to get through the smoke
hanging over the whole area not much had
really taken place in terms of policing
the area the image is still vivid in my
mind is the carnage folks were still
sitting around in the days they hadn't
done much hadn't even taken ponchos and
covered up these bodies I could handle
the conversation I could handle grown
men crying but we were talking 12 hours
later sitting there feeling sorry for
themselves Colonel Brown was very pissed
off even if you do get caught in a bad
situation you have to do something to
recover it was young kids who paid the
price in later years I used to stress
that to my young battery commanders it
isn't us who died in combat
it's those young kids who died those
kids we are responsible for training and
leading it's our job to get the job done
and get those kids home safe
then here they're wrapping up this again
now this the the battle turned and and
really the Vietnamese left after the
massive airstrikes had started and
here's another image of the cleanup back
to the book specialist for John wiliness
of Bravo Company 2nd battalion 7th
cavalry mortar platoon and most of the
rest of de Derrick's men were involved
in this McCobb depressing duty
it was incredible carnage we went into
areas where lots of artillery had come
in during the night and we saw our guys
had been blown up in the trees the
bodies were already decomposed and it
only happened night before we were in
shock it was the first last and only
time I ever saw anything like it and I
pray never again the stench was
unbelievable we started hauling in the
whole bodies first then we brought in
the pieces and parts two Chinooks came
in and we loaded one with about 20
corpses neatly arranged in litters the
pilot began preparing to take off one of
our officers pointed m16 at the pilot
told him to keep the board on the ground
we weren't through bodies were loaded
floor to ceiling when the ramp finally
closed blood poured through the hinges I
felt sorry for the poor bastards who
would have to unload this chopper back
at Holloway the nightmares
born of this battle have never faded him
the final Division Headquarters account
reported that the two-seven alpha and
Bravo companies and the one-five
battalion suffered a hundred and fifty
one men killed in action 121 wounded and
four missing in action and on April 6
1966 so quite some months later Hal
Moore who was at that time had become
the third brigade commander went back to
LZ Albany and recovered the bodies of
all four members of 2:7 who were brought
back on a helo and began the long
journey home to America now this was as
I said kind of the the the tipping point
in the Vietnam War and this battle had a
impact strategically one thing that came
from this battle and I'll talk about a
little bit more in the book but the body
count came back and the body count came
back basically as ten to one or maybe
twelve to one so for every ten or twelve
North Vietnamese soldier that was dead
there was only one American killed and
our generals liked that ratio they
thought hey you know we can win a war of
attrition and one of the comments that
comes in in the book as they go back in
an interview general G app who's the the
senior general of the North Vietnamese
Army he's got a book actually what we're
gonna do in the podcast at some point
he's the mastermind of the strategy and
he said we thought that the Americans
must have a strategy we did we had the
strategy of a people's war no part of
what that means is that the strategy of
the people's war means we're gonna we're
gonna suffer some casualties and we're
okay with that so our strategy of saying
well we'll get them into a war of
attrition they're okay with it
they don't care human life has less
human a human life has less value for
them at this time the commander's sure
as hell didn't care you know we talked
about that last time they're losing guys
on the from malaria on the trail you're
gonna lose five six guys they don't care
they've got a war to win so talking
about some of the other sort of
strategic things or strategic
implications from this 1967 so this is a
couple years later back to the book in
mid-december President Johnson convened
a White House meeting of his top
advisors will Bundy says that McNamara's
option number one get the hell out of
Vietnam now while the getting is good
was never seriously considered nor was
it pressed by McNamara option number two
the huge buildup of American combat and
support troops was readily approved by
all including McNamara ever the numbers
cruncher McNamara told The Gathering the
military solution to the problem is not
certain the odds of success are one out
of three or one out of two McNamara did
push for a bombing pause to prepare us
opinion public opinion for the coming
escalation so again well I'm sure at
some point on this podcast we will dive
deep into the political manipulation the
political decision-making that happened
during the Vietnam War but this is this
is what they're talking about it's
interesting to hear McNamara
even back in 1967 is saying hey we got
like a one-in-three maybe one and two
odds of winning this this not it's not
that's not good odds we don't like those
odds
here's here's how more talking again
back to the book in late June 1966 my
turn was up as commander of the third
Brigade when my replacement Herr Colonel
straight out of the Pentagon showed up
to take over my Brigade was in the field
fighting near dong Trey
it would have been criminal in those
circumstances to relinquish my command
to him to man who still who's still
pissing stateside water and I flatly
refused to do so the change of command
was delayed 10 days until the fight was
over a month later on August 8 1966 my
replacement sent my replacement sent
Alpha Company 1st battalion 7th cavalry
back in the hydrating-- Valley by itself
and 25 men were killed in one terrible
day so not a good turnover situation and
again this is where this is where the
beer you people always talk about when I
talk with businesses they go you we have
a big bureaucracy here and you don't
understand like no we understand the
military understands per actually better
than anybody we probably got the biggest
and most most firm in place bureaucracy
in the world and this is part of it
right here back to look I had hoped that
my next assignment would be to the
infantry school at Fort Benning where I
could pass along what I had learned in
Vietnam for the young officers who were
headed for combat it was not to be in
fact only one of the hundreds of
officers who had gone through air mobile
training and a year in the field with
the 1st Cavalry Division was assigned to
the infantry school I was sent instead
to Washington DC where I was told my nap
next job would be Latin American desk at
the US State Department this is this is
an embarrassment right here's this guy
basically created or helped create or
helped test the the idea of air mobile
helicopter assaults and then he did it
for a year in the field commanded at the
battalion end at the brigade level
and instead of putting him in the
infantry score he could teach the stuff
that he learned they sent him to be the
the the Latin American desk and I'll
tell you what's awesome this was awesome
when I was in the SEAL Teams I went to
Ramadi when I came home guess where I
went I took over the West Coast SEAL
training for the for the guys that were
getting ready to deploy around
Afghanistan
I did what he wanted to do which is
perfect and luckily we have the a little
a little less bureaucracy and I was able
to talk to my boss and say hey this is
what I would be doing yeah you're right
and put me in that position but it
didn't happen and here's all this
knowledge gone and they said only one
officer out of a hundred hmm that's
another thing like when you hear you
know people in the business world they
say what the military is this great
organization the military has all kinds
of problems military is no perfect no
perfect example of the way to run things
parts of it are but you can't look at
the military to hold and say that that
even remotely makes sense in any way
shape or form and I could point a
thousand things out to you today the
military is the same way doing dumb
stuff I mean it's a great organization
there's got great people there's there's
unbelievable leaders in there but
there's also idiots hmm the military is
made up of people of human beings
brilliant ones dumb ones
back to the book for the next year I
watched Bob McNamara and John McNaughton
both brilliant men go through hell as
they struggled unsuccessfully to get a
handle on the war and the pacification
progress in Vietnam at the end of that
year neither of them was either you know
neither of them was any closer to
finding or creating such a handle an
office wit summed up what was happening
in Vietnam sadly and succinctly although
we have redouble our efforts we have
lost sight of our objective so upon all
this troops in there upon all this money
in there put all this all these assets
in there we've we've redoubled our
efforts but we've lost sight of our
objective back to the book what then had
we learned with our sacrifices in the I
drank Valley we had learned something
about fighting the North Vietnamese
regulars and something important about
ourselves we could stand against the
finest light infantry troops in the
world and hold our ground
general Westmoreland thought he had
found the answer to the question of how
to win this war he would train one
American life for 10 or 11 or 12 North
Vietnamese lives
day after day until Ho Chi Minh cried
uncle Westmoreland would learn too late
that he was wrong
that the American people didn't see a
kill ratio of 10 to 1 or even 20 to 1 as
any kind of bargain but we had validated
both the principle and the practice of
airmobile warfare a million American
soldiers would ride to battle in Huey
helicopters for the next eight years and
the familiar woke of their rotors would
be the enduring soundtrack of this war
finally even though it took 10 years
cost the lives of 58,000
Americans inflicted humiliating defeat
on a nation that had never before lost a
war
some of us learned that Clausewitz had
it right a hundred and fifty years
earlier when he wrote these words no one
starts a war or rather no one in his
senses ought to do so without first
being clear in his mind what he intends
to achieve by that war and how he
intends to conduct it
Clausewitz to be clear in your mind in
what you intend to achieve know what you
are going to do that doesn't seem like
too much to ask
certainly in war and you wouldn't think
it would be too much for people to ask
in their lives either their precious
lives as precious as these 58,000 that
died in Vietnam heroes but how often do
we see people going through their lives
without knowing what they are trying to
do without having any intent without
having a clear mission I'm talking on an
individual level as a person people go
through their lives without knowing what
it is they want to do what they want to
accomplish
so know what your mission is know what
your intent as the commander of your
life know what your intent is and then
fight with everything you've got to win
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight so let go maybe if you want to
shed some light on how people can maybe
help themselves win that war sure and
maybe support the podcast if they want
to they want to yeah that point though
in my opinion is it good it's a good one
it's a good one think about you people
go through their lives I don't know what
they're trying to do yeah and it sounds
the same thing as going to war without
knowing what the outcome is supposed to
be yeah
your goal but it sounds kind of like
obvious when you say it you know like
hey go through you know when you go
through life should you have a goal real
obvious yes you're gonna say no you
shouldn't have a goal kind of thing so
it seems obvious but you know how you
live day to day you you know you might
have a goal for the day maybe two maybe
three but Brett life is full life is a
full spectrum of stuff well again it's
so shocking because what you're saying
is absolutely true you wouldn't think
that people would be going through life
without knowing where they're trying to
get to but you wouldn't think that a
nation would go to war without clear
intention of where they want to end up
and how they're gonna get there and then
how you gonna get there now I have a
little bit of like when clouds Fitz says
how you're gonna conduct the war that's
not necessarily true cuz you don't know
you can't know how you're gonna conduct
the war before the war starts you can
have an idea but you can't know fully
just like if you were to say hey my goal
is to X in my life you don't know how
you're gonna be able to do that yeah cuz
you talkin about cuz you're gonna just
gonna make it adaptations things are
gonna come up things are gonna change
the battlefield changes your life
changes things pop up I mean things
happen so I think that that idea that
you're gonna know how you're gonna
execute something is is far-fetched I
think you well actually I should use the
word idea you should have an idea of how
you're gonna do it yeah you should have
an idea like okay well this is what I
need to get done this is what I want to
achieve in my life yeah I want to make I
want to do this
mmm-hmm what's the simple one I want to
own a house that's a simple one that's a
good place to start yeah I want to own a
house okay well let's think about how
we're gonna get there you know that's
that's let's think about how we're gonna
get there you have to build your credit
you have to have how do you build your
credit you have to you have to borrow
money some people something they go to
buy a house they've never borrowed money
before you can't borrow money if you've
never borrowed money you can't borrow
money for a house if you've never
borrowed money for a car or a or a or
some smaller object before so you got to
establish your credit then you gotta
have two years worth of income then you
gotta have a big fat downpayment sitting
ready so there's things you got to do
this thing good now now that might
change the car along the way the idea is
that you got to move towards that goal
that's what was so nice about hearing
the vietnamese commander's intent get
close split them up yeah boom you go
make that happen
hey guess what you want to buy a house
one day save money have good credit yeah
okay well you got to make money how you
make money you might make it drive an
uber you might make it
delivering pizza you might make it you
got your real job with that support in
your family but then you need a little
extra to throw in there well that's why
you end up driving uber you end up
whatever it is you're gonna do you let
me make you some money on the side that
you can start stashing away yeah yeah
and at the end of the day you do have
that goal you know so it is yeah how you
conduct yourself not gonna cut and dry
for sure but you know in these examples
like you know you want to buy a house
that's a goal that specifically but
that's just one teeny tiny goal in life
if you're of course you're not gonna run
into somebody who their only goal in
life is to buy a house some people like
a don't buy a house it's stupid you
should rent them yes fine yeah I'm not
telling everyone what their goal should
be and if you want to keep renting keep
renting maybe that's for you yeah yeah
fully not for me yeah no babies for you
there's other things you want to put
your money that's cool you're doing some
other something else smart with your
money yeah that's fine yeah like buying
rims or something like that
either way though if you uh consider
like just what went possibly closer to
tightening what what do you think in
compared to life rent we're buying house
sure that's one of many goals you can
have in life because life is full like
it but so it kind of when you really
think about it bright it's hard
it's hard to like designate some
specific goals and then that's all
you're gonna okay let's say you're gonna
you're gonna say you're gonna be
financially secure and independent okay
that would be a much bigger loss right
yeah that's an awesome goal to have and
the younger you make that goal but
better chance you have of achieving it
yeah because now you're not wasting your
money you're actually saving for a house
so you can get that house paid off so
now you don't have a mortgage anywhere
you know it's like yeah that's a bigger
goal that's a broader goal just like
when you when you go to war you need to
know what it is you're going to war for
what are you gonna do and what are you
gonna stop and what's your intended
result yeah so you gotta in a way you
got to fill your life with a bunch of
goals so you don't get gem cuz you have
small goals that lead to the big goal
right so for instance you want to be
financially secure and stable what are
you gonna do you're gonna save some of
your money okay that's one thing you're
gonna buy a house that's another thing
you're gonna pay off your car and you're
not gonna buy expensive dumb cars you're
gonna buy cheap cars until you have the
money to buy him with cash you're gonna
make all these little things you're
gonna work extra you're gonna you know
you're gonna do these things so you're
right you have you have your broad goal
yes you have your long-term goal yes and
then you got your short-term goals that
lead and are strategically aligned with
that long-term goal it's the same thing
in war you have to have those both those
things going on yeah yeah and then on
top of that she won't have the last word
today don't you no no no no no I'm
making this part
every time I concisely close out what
you're trying to show you you add
because it's not that I mean it is that
but then you're talking about life now
and here's kind of the point where you
say okay you say but one example is
financial like you want to buy a house
you want to be financially secure that's
one goal but in life there's more to
life than just financial so you want
your hell few money Layton ships you
want your like there's all these things
that you you kind of hope or want to be
solid yeah we'll say so but most people
don't really put it in perspective that
clearly like okay you know I'm gonna
register I want this Mercedes goals if
you have goals yes if you have those in
those areas then you can you know you
can you guys
avoid maneuver towards I'm exactly right
avoid distractions all this stuff rain
and fight and fight towards those goals
sounds obvious but that's what I'm
saying it's like hard to like designate
each goal in life oh I'd say this is
gonna be easy
yeah that's me it's not that hard if you
sat down for 20 minutes I bet you could
come up with some solid life go that's
kind of the that's kind of the point I
was making where it's very busy cruising
really it's about this just being
distracted I think that's what it is you
know and if the clear your goal the more
I think control you can have over being
distracted or not cuz like if your goal
isn't that clear it's almost like it's
not gonna be clear or it is you won't
really be clear when you're being
distracted or not kind of thing people
don't and I'm saying people I mean
myself we don't live our lives like just
in constant pursuit of all our specific
goals we it's like a lot of life is
minute-to-minute man no you can you can
have some sections that you can carve
out so you can live like that but yeah
that's not where you are nothing how
you're rolling yeah no no it's not how
it should be so if you'll notice in life
I think like any any solid goal that
you've achieved you'll notice that that
it took that clear goal and you just
didn't get distracted and you just want
for it so it's like you've done it for
yourself and there's also just like
being on the path yeah that's thinking
about jiu-jitsu right my goal in
jiu-jitsu is never to get a black belt
I never said like I want to be a black
belt or never I never even fought that
yeah I just wanted to get better at this
thing right okay so and not to get it
wasn't--oh yeah like never you go with
me Oh was that to get a black button my
goal was to Train Jitsu and get better
at Jiu Jitsu
yeah then therefore comes my goal was
like even finances I wasn't like hey I
want to make X amount money I was like I
want to be able to do whatever I want to
do yeah so let's move in that direction
yeah that might not even have a
financial value like there's some people
that do whatever they want to do but
they have a very low income but they set
themselves up in such a way that
they're allowed to do what they want to
do Chuck
alright are you doing the last word no
no no anyway oh yeah support right
that's what we were talking about all
right
yeah you can suppose I wanted to hear
you talking when you pursue goals yeah
you may or may not need support I
recommend support supporting yourself
support of others from others for others
to a street kind anyway if one of your
goals is to maintain physical shape and
capability is important
I work out right you work out yep yeah
good so I work out right and you know
how so my wife will give me grief
sometimes cuz I'll just like work out at
the wrong time you know cuz in my mind
like working out so important right so I
can like glow about you
yes so I can loosely justify it oh yeah
you know yeah it's dinner time but hey
my health right and sometimes so she'll
frame it like oh yeah you choose to like
work on your work on your body or
something like that and I say no it's
help its capability it's true but the
point there is it's important no matter
how you frame it or your wife frames it
it's important yeah you want to do it
strategic anyway while doing that you
take krill oil take stuff that helps
maintain the structural integrity of
your body and the good news is chocolate
supplements for that krill oil
jock goes super krill and joint warfare
I've been taking these consistently in
solid legit
Thank You Jocko also John has a new one
called discipline it's a pre mission if
your if your mission is a workout it's a
pre workout if your mission is a
studying it's a pretty study studying
pre studying supplement you know
pre-mission little uh cognitive
enhancers in there little bit of
caffeine microdose right you like to
make it yeah yeah you don't want to get
all strong caffeine it's just the
perfect amount essentially also if you
our own let me tell you where to get
these things point yeah because they're
not just floating out there anyway go to
origin main comm that's where you know
also in or Jemaine calm you can get cool
G's a lot of people still know still
asking me maybe not every day I'm not
every other every other day but they
still ask me what geese should I get
I started did you did to what he should
I get his once origin yeast one hundred
percent not even 99% 100% or jinkies a
big range to choose from
they also got rash guards in there
compression gear for any other activity
you like some fashion stuff to bring in
two fashions know a little bit know
little bit on it all a little bit also
you mean they have a plain black victory
mmm a teacher no we have oh okay
that's my level - yeah well it happens
to be on jaw closed or dot-com but I'll
get to that first things first
just check if you're doing did you say
that origin stuff isn't made in here in
America no big deal yeah it's no big
deal
this made in America yeah I think it's a
big deal but I don't like oh you're not
gonna focus on because you know the
quality kind of leads with this one or
they could go hand-in-hand is is it good
quality because it's made in America or
is it made in America because it's good
quality yeah well both its it's good
quality cuz made in America by qualified
craftsmen yes I think that's really the
case yeah and some of you know one of my
buddies just he's he was on deployment
had an origin key shipped over on the
opponent and he came home from
deployment and he'd been training while
he was on deployment and he's like bro
that origin key is the best thing ever I
was like yeah oh yeah it is yeah for
sure so anyways and it's made in America
so yeah from the cotton the cotton
that's grown here in America would he
call
processed here in America woven in
America made into a key in America you
can wear it wherever you want but oh you
can't wear you wherever you want
actually more or less no with no there's
some tension a lot dirty key yeah yeah
Club noogie
grocery store noogie yeah yeah
have you ever want to eat a grocery
store no me neither
I've I've never worn my ghee outside of
a Jiu Jitsu Academy me and I'm confirmed
what about watering right now what about
the pain you're either going to
jiu-jitsu or a little bit too and I
don't you just change there yeah you
change there what if I just started
rolling in the key all the time like
outside yeah yeah you know what little
kids do it yeah that's throws the Gion
yeah she's no problem she walk around
the supermarket no she's a little thing
market if she's ready representing
Sookie choke somebody yeah Ezekiel where
Nikki in the story you'd be tactically
sound you know achieving her goals focus
to demonstrate not being distracted it's
good nonetheless you're gonna get Aggie
again I'll say it now I'll say it again
I'll meet America in America or gin mein
Kampf boom select whatever you want get
to I've to set three actually wait no
then you discipline equals freedom yeah
I got that one so three you know
together and boom origin I'm gonna get a
black one too by the way that's you know
also working out you doing jujitsu maybe
you're doing weightlifting maybe you're
running whatever I say do kettlebells
and when you do kettlebells get the
cooler from on it on it on it calm slash
job go look for the primal belt my
opinion actually the zombie ones are
pretty dope too but get those that's
what I think makes it work out more
interesting I did one yesterday it was
interesting kind of hard to but
nonetheless yeah get they get them from
there they got a lot of cool stuff on
there for interesting workouts you want
to switch it up if you want to do the
same like if your workout is boring or
something like that get like that get
some battle ropes
go through one of those workouts you did
one like that before or a battle ropes
workout because I have yeah yeah
interesting it kind of makes your like
syrettes Katniss or you know what that
is
your intercostal muscles yeah and it
down there nonetheless anyway on it
calms less job with a three get them
solid site also when you are getting
this book we were soldiers once than
young actually I thought it was we were
soldiers once in young and I was like
wait no it's We Were Soldiers Once and
young and young and by the way we were
young kind of thing anyway you get that
book good book outstanding book go great
title when you see like my wife will do
something that there'll be like young
seals at yeah and my wife's always like
so young yeah they look so young
you know and that's what you always
think yeah I think that these kids are
so young and then I was one of those
kids yeah and yeah they are young you
know that's who fights worse
young kids well that's 18 19 20 22 years
old 23 years old that's who fights Wars
yeah yeah and it's crazy and JP kind of
talks about this where your maturity
kind of gets on this like fast track
when you jump in the military it doesn't
it doesn't in film life it doesn't it
doesn't because you're also
institutionalized oh yeah so you don't
like when you're in the mill that's what
hurts some guys when they get out of the
military they're like wait a second I
don't wait well has my paycheck supposed
to come every two weeks now it's not
there oh I used to it
yeah oh you have a mission here's how
you're gonna do and that when you're in
the military you just here's your
clothes that you're gonna wear yeah you
don't I mean make sense here's the
haircut that you're gonna happen you get
all the military else and you're like
you don't have this direction anymore
yeah so you do get it matures you in
some ways but in other ways you get
stunted to growth that's why he gets
some fun guys doing dumb shit when
they're 30 years old 38 years old 42
years old yeah they're doing the midlife
crisis thing but when you think when you
I mean it's not even amid that they're
just trying to figure it out yes I
haven't had right they didn't do that
like that's the time is everyone else
but you know you talk about your wife
looks at it the younger guys are the
seal sensei oh they look so young
that's I think that's like an indicator
that she doesn't feel old you know cuz
you're not like when you're when you
kind of like I I do the same thing when
I look at college football when I watch
the college-football cuz I remember when
I was when I was playing football
oh yeah there is a guy 26 years old on
my team 26 yeah it didn't he'll be as
kind of go involved in stuff like that
but nonetheless he's 26 26 is young by
the way and depending on how old you are
because when you're 16 yeah you don't
think you if I tried to ask my son who's
15 like what what how far away 25 years
or how long was it until he was 25 like
he would understand 10 years he has no
you would not be able to like
cognitively assess what a 25 year old
human being is thinking about he's not
got it going on yeah but I feel like
you'd still be able to figure out okay
25 you know people when do people die of
old age quote unquote would be what a
tease right you know whenever so you
figured 25 so what less than a 30-year
life mmm 26 less than a third that would
be considered old technically if they
were to think about I think a 50 year 15
year old would grasp on those 26 year
old was old usual yeah I thought so
so when I look back and then me I don't
feel old as old as I am I don't feel
like Oh old I think back when I was in
like college or whatever and I think
about the number of my current age and I
think dang that's that's all that's the
older person being that older person now
I don't feel like how I've thought that
older person in the film right and I
really think that now it really comes
and gets put into perspective when I
watch college football and I seem take
off their helmet like dang that is a
child right there playing college
football performing out performing like
super good but they just look so young
I'm just like your wife they look so
young but it's because I don't feel like
it old person that's what that's good
yeah I guess so but cuz you know if you
feel like whole person you're like yeah
they look young because they're young
they're
okay I'm an old person there you feel
like you she could be in there too my
god yeah and then you see okay you know
one of those things nonetheless back to
support when you buy this book We Were
Soldiers Once and young go to jakku
podcast calm we got a section that all
the books that this book listed by
episode all the books listed by episode
plus a few other ones boom click through
there we got you taste you direct link
amazon prime you prime right I do
one day shipping same day she went
sometimes yeah anyway get it there good
way to support and if you're gonna do
other shopping carry-on good way to
support also chocolates door and I'm
gonna talk about it
but before I do that I think if you
subscribe to the podcast as good way to
support what I was gonna say subscribe
if you haven't already seems obvious
let's subscribe leave a review on iTunes
if you subscribe to iTunes if you want
to leave a review if you're feeling
reluctant just get over it leave the
review also YouTube subscribe P tube
video version of this podcast also
excerpts various types of excerpts you
know so you can share if you don't share
the whole two-and-a-half hour podcast
with people there are excerpts if you
wanted to share an individual concept
with people they can boom they can get
that concept and you know share it
mm-hmm internalize it you know what I
mean also chuckle is the store it's
called yuckle store Java store calm sure
its t-shirts rash guards hoodies some
patches on their hats on their just it's
the stuff I'll say it's cool stuff I
wouldn't be pushing stuff that I didn't
think was cool and it's chocolate kind
of the pink shirts aren't choco but
nonetheless if you want to get shirts
and stuff that's where it is chocolate
or calm they are good
they are good they're not like the cheap
ones that's what I'm saying so well you
can rest assured but yeah and what you
think if you have one hey people take
pictures of themselves with the shirt on
and they say this is a good shirt and
that's good I encourage that and if you
don't like this shirt let me know -
there it is also good way to support
yourself one of the better ways in my
opinion depends on what kind of person
you are is psychological warfare if you
don't know what that is it's an album
with tracks with Jocko on each track
telling you that in your on your
campaign against weakness when you when
you hit those roadblocks that's what it
is rope that's what they are roadblocks
mental fatigue distractions all this
stuff these tracks will help you through
it
it's chocolate telling you pragmatically
giving you practical information and
advice how to get over those roadblocks
or around those roadblocks or through
those roadblocks I'm gonna make a
psychological warfare track and then
it's gonna be directed toward you make
you talk about this stuff faster okay
well here's the thing when I you know I
come across this smart right yeah see I
feel compelled to share the valuable
points that I think are valuable that
I've used or that I felt with each thing
but then I'm like oh wait that'll take a
long time to explain so you don't seem
to care sometimes they don't but today
you're down jack I think it's valuable
okay we'll go with that no watch how
fast I do this yeah but you're not gonna
give them the whole thing you know like
the choco white tea you know you didn't
demonstrate in that demonstrate explain
yeah that choco white tea guaranteed to
get your dad left to 8,000 pounds no
that's it done next
plus there's three books you can get way
the warrior kid gets kids on the path
boom done actually four shot more about
kid that's cool no need I don't know man
but I think like I read way the word kid
to my daughter every single night it's
one or two chapters not too long just
one or two chapters so she wants to read
the next chapter she wanted she wants me
to read the next chapter that night I
said no tomorrow she's looking forward
to it everything like that's just the
mantra the whole way and the warrior kid
is just a background to you for life yes
good thing to know don't be weak like
work hard all this stuff I would explain
that whole thing because I just said
because that's the value that I got way
the warrior kid if you want a longer
explanation you can email echo and he'll
give it to you extreme ownership same
thing combat leadership for business and
life that's new version just came out
has a little Q&A from you all from the
podcast that's in there so you can get
that also for an individual perspective
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
it's available everywhere there's no
better gift than discipline the audio
version of that which people ask me
about a lot is not on audible.com it is
on its it's an album with tracks
actually you can get it from iTunes
Amazon music Google Play other mp3
platforms for leadership also beyond the
podcast beyond the books we have a
leadership consulting company it's me
Lafe Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke
you can email info at Ashkelon front
comm if you want to book a speaker
don't call speaker's bureau or a
speaker's agent don't just go to issue
on front comm fill out the form and one
of us will come talk to you your company
on top of that we got something called
the muster also known as the monster
we're doing two of them this year only
why we don't have enough room in the
schedule to do three again Washington DC
May 17th and 18th San Francisco
California October 17th and 18th come
and get it
extreme ownership calm that's where you
register
there's some video stuff about it yeah
that's that also if you want to ask us
more questions or you have answers to
questions or points to make outside of
the podcast and you want to get in touch
with us you can do it on the interwebs
Twitter Instagram that is where you can
find us EKKO is at echo Charles and I am
at Jocko willing and to those people out
there the soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines around the world right now
standing watch thank you for protecting
our nation and our freedoms and a police
in law enforcement thanks for watching
our backs here at home and protecting us
from evil in our own backyard to the
firefighters that walk into fire to keep
us safe
and the paramedics that keep us alive
first responders thanks to all of you
for what you do and to everyone out
there make sure you have a plan make
sure you have a goal make sure you have
intent make sure you have a mission and
then get out there and get after it and
until next time this is echo and Jocko
out